have you seen the people wearing these
dumb Apple things apples come out with
goggles and they're goggles you put them
on your head and I think there's audio
associated with it and it covers up half
your face and they cost 3,500 bucks plus
200 bucks for a battery pack but here's
the here's the promise is if you spend a
lot of money and you put these dumb
looking goggles on your face you get to
live inside a cell phone you get do you
ever think in your Modern Life you think
you know I just don't look at enough
screens I I wish I could spend more time
I wish my phone were more immersive and
I didn't have to look at you know uh
this beautiful Earth and Sky that God
gave to us to live in real life in our
flesh I wish I could just ignore all
that so I could be on my cell phone more
well then have I got the product for you
it's the Apple Vision Pro some guy just
got pulled over for driving it was a
Tesla so I guess it was a self-driving
car but he was driving with his Apple
goggles on and the video starts out all
sort of nice
he's he's not touching the steering
wheel
he's looks like he's casting a magic
spell of sorts cuz he's typing onto the
air so it it actually kind of looks like
he's Jordan Peterson you know like he's
doing one of these things with his hands
you know man but he's not but without
any of the wisdom you know without any
of the insightful observations and then
it immediately cuts to the guy gets
pulled over by a police
officer CS Lewis observed in the Great
divorce that the people who are in Hell
want to be there hell is a place that
you
choose hell is where you go by your own
desire because you do not turn your
desire and behavior toward God you turn
it in the other direction and you get
what you want that's the that's the
amazing thing about Freedom whether we
follow it in a proper way or we abuse it
is you tend to get what you
want
if you to told not just George Orwell
but aldus
Huxley in the in the early to mid 20th
century if you said Hey in the
future people are going to be so
addicted to screens and to constant
titilation and to just buzzes and alarms
and a ton of porn by the way that at a
certain point they're going to block out
their own Vision they're going to choose
to put these goggles on and blur out the
real world so that they can watch sports
and porn all day even while they're
driving Huxley would believe you George
Orwell would think that that would be
imposed by a tyrannical totalitarian
government Huxley was smarter
though
because while George Orwell in 1984
believes that our our loss of freedom is
going to come through the heavy hand of
the state Aldis Huxley in Brave New
World recognizes no it's going to be the
carrot not the stick he recognizes no
it's going to be the enticement it's
going to be the temptation to all sorts
of low pleasures and and all sorts of
vices that's what's going to get us it's
going to be drugs and sex and
promiscuity and just physical pleasure
and that's what's going to happen I can
think of no product that I would I would
less enjoy than the Apple Vision
Pro but a lot of people are going to buy
this thing it's it's expensive so it's
that is naturally going to limit who can
buy it but a lot of people are going to
desire this thing that's for sure
they're going to live in virtual
reality which they have convince
themselves is is more beautiful and
interesting than reality reality but
it's not and this by the way this is in
part why we have the as people just no
longer value the physical world they
they only value the virtual and digital
world in in which a man can really
become a woman because their bodies
don't matter but I I still prefer the
physical world and I would encourage you
not to plug not to voluntarily plug
yourself into the Matrix where you can
watch football and pornography all day
long speaking of our changing political
order sad news coming out of the UK this
is
news about which most Americans will not
care but I do care actually his majesty
King Charles III has been diagnosed with
cancer uh King Charles you know just
became king his mother reigned for 70
years and then he ascended to the throne
when she died and he was he was just
crowned what a year or two ago and uh he
went in for a a routine kind of prostate
uh procedure which men of a certain age
virtually all undergo and while they
were in there they found that he had
some kind of cancer nonprostate cancer
some other kind of cancer the Buckingham
Palace has not been totally clear about
what cancer that is and I just think we
ought to pray for King Charles I know we
broke away from those limes back in
1776 I
know some Catholics don't really like
the The Windsor because they're
Protestant or okay sure but some
conservatives don't like King Charles
because they say he's a world economic
Forum environmentalist stooge or what
because he divorced his wife I know I
know I I know all the Litany of charges
against King
Charles
nevertheless
that man is I think by his inclination
but certainly by his
office one of the most traditionalist
and conservative people left on the face
of the Earth even King Charles's
environmentalism is very very
conservative because he's not an
environmentalist in the way that your
lesbian cousin is an environmentalist
you know your lesbian vegan cousin with
silly colored hair who shows up to
Thanksgiving and yells at you for eating
turkey that's not the kind of Environ
environmentalist King Charles is King
Charles is the kind of environmentalist
who wants to protect the woodlands on
his property so he can continue to hunt
foxes and that's extremely conservative
King jles is the kind of
environmentalist who believes we need to
protect the world so that the natural
world so that we can continue to enjoy
it because it's beautiful and old and
traditional he's the kind of
environmentalist who likes the
environment because he opposes rampant
liberal capitalism and industrialization
that's very conservative that's very
very traditional the British crown is is
one of the few remaining even quasi
conservative institutions in the world
and so anyway that's my long rant and
diet tribe to uh pray for King Charles
because even though we Americans we
think we don't we know who cares about
the British crown even plenty of people
in the UK say oh whatever get rid of the
the crown you will miss that institution
if
it ever goes away you will miss it
because there will be a lot of
dignity that will disappear there will
be there will be un
unlearned knowledge that just kind of
gets passed down hered through through
the generations as a matter of heredity
it will disappear and you will miss it
when it's gone there is a great new bill
being put forward by a house Republican
that every house Republican should get
behind
the the Republicans in the house they're
doing a good job right now they're
killing that dumb immigration Bill and
now they are proposing the face act
repeal this is coming by way of
Congressman chip Roy and I think it's
absolutely great and every Republican
should back chip Roy's plan the face Act
was a law signed by Bill Clinton in 1994
it's the freedom of access to Clinic
entrances act it was a it was a way to
protect abortion clinics from
criticism because was in the '90s the
libs claimed that the poor the poor
beleaguered abortionists the poor baby
murderers were being threatened too much
and so we we had to figure out a way to
stop people from threatening them but it
wasn't really just about threats the
face act very quickly became weaponized
to stop conservatives from peaceful
protests peaceful demonstrations you're
seeing pro-lifers being prosecuted and
sent to prison for more than a decade
for this sort of thing right now and it
was controversial at the time so the
Liberals gave the conservatives a bone
and they said okay well in the face act
we'll also stop people from intimidating
uh uh churchgoers we'll stop people from
vandalizing churches Joe Biden has not
prosecuted one of these cases a face act
case against someone attacking a church
that just doesn't happen it was bogus it
was it was a a total distraction this
act is about the protecting baby
murderers from criticism act that's what
you could call it and so Chip Roy very
wisely and very courageously just came
out and said let's repeal this stupid
thing and I absolutely think it's a
great idea and and I rarely get on my
Soap Box on this show and say call your
Congressman but when it comes to the
face act repeal call your Congressman
tag your Congressman if you're watching
this on YouTube tag your Congressman on
YouTube if you're watching this on
Twitter tag on X tag your Congressman if
you're watching this on dailywire plus
send this link
around this is a great bill every
Republican should get behind this and it
it's it's an urgent matter because
people are being prosecuted under this
stupid law this face act right now and
good people are going to prison for
Having the courage to stand up for the
most defenseless Among
Us call your Congressman man what a
great clip that was now hold up wait
wait wait wait hold on ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel we'll see you next time